some were highly anticipated some looked
intriguing on the surface but failed to
deliver and some struggle to even make
the public aware of their existence but
they all have one thing in common they
tanked badly at the box office
base on a notoriously dangerous
real-life New Jersey theme park action
point star Johnny Knoxville of Jackass
Fame has the irresponsible owner of the
most dangerous vacation spot in America
featuring plenty of actual life and limb
threatening stunts from its seasoned
performers actionpoint promised lowbrow
belly laughs along the lines of the
Jackass film series there was only one
problem the movie's awful fans found the
theme park narrative to be awkwardly
grafted onto what could easily have just
been another jackass movie even though
Knoxville practically killed himself
making the movie the stunts were also
seen as uninspired and the laughs were
few and far between
despite the premise and the pedigree to
be a potential horror classic Winchester
was just a disappointment Dame Helen
Mirren starred as Sarah Winchester
heiress to the gun manufacturers fortune
who spent decades building strange
additions onto her famous mansion the
film posited that her bizarre
architecture choices were driven by
something decidedly supernatural
unfortunately Winchester relies on cheap
jump scares and questionable plotting in
lieu of anything resembling atmosphere
or tension I hope everything has been to
your satisfaction so far cannot fault
the hospitality it's quite a special
house is it not the John Travolta biopic
got he got a lot of press due to its
star and subject infamous mob boss John
Gotti leading up to its screening a can
but its reception at the festival was
less than rapturous and upon its June
release in the u.s. few critics bothered
to review it literally every single one
that did panned it leading the film
social media account to pin its
subsequent poor box-office showing on
unfair negative reviews literally every
aspect of the film's production was
roundly blasted from its lack of
coherent themes in ham-fisted direction
to Travolta's terrible lead performance
the movie failed to even make back half
of its paltry 10 million dollar budget
which is a sure sign of movie failure a
futuristic sci-fi thriller with a cast
most directors would kill for didn't
stop Hotel Artemus from completely
tanking at the box office part of the
problem was that director drew Pierce's
preference for sky
over substance resulted in a great
premise falling flat worse the film's
marketing largely free of plot or
character details did nothing to pull
audiences in those willing to take the
plunge were met with a convoluted plot
laced with laborious needlessly
expository dialogue despite its modest
15 million dollar budget hotel Artemus
didn't even crack half that at the
domestic box office as any good hotel
owner will tell you you just can't turn
a profit with that kind of vacancy rate
the darkest minds seem to come with a
built-in audience it's an adaptation of
the well-received young adult novel of
the same name and features super-powered
characters that could have come straight
from the latest x-men movie
unfortunately critics took the film to
task for being muddled confusing and
trite and it whipped with audiences as
well failing to even clear six million
dollars in its opening weekend many
critics felt that mines is guilty of
pandering to its audience giving them a
predictable story full of tired cliches
and obvious plot twists in the case of
the darkest minds it seemed like
assembling rehashed plot points from
better movies wasn't enough to get
audiences to care many critics thought
that alpha would be a welcome return to
form for Albert Hughes who is partly
responsible for the classic hard-boiled
crime pictures menace to society and
dead presidents alpha tells the story of
a prehistoric youth who become separated
from his hunting group and in order to
survive partners up with a lone wolf
abandoned by its pack it's a thrilling
gorgeously shot adventure but while the
film scored with critics it failed to
connect with audiences with an
advertising campaign which seemed to be
aimed more squarely at dog lovers than
fans of epic adventure alpha simply
didn't generate the kind of positive
word-of-mouth that it needed it also had
the misfortune of squaring off against
crazy rich Asians in the Meg two films
which destroyed at the box office
alpha failed to make back its budget
domestically but it seems destined for a
robust second life on home video
[Music]